la commission des finances elle ne
revient pas au groupe le plus important
elle revient à un groupe de l'opposition
et par ailleurs traditionnellement le
traditionnel mais c'est pas extra mais
c'est vrai
j'ai fait selon le règlement intérieur
de l'assemblée nationale par ailleurs
nous sommes le groupe le plus important
puisque dans la commission finances nous
aurons plus de commissaires que le front
national donc sur ces deux points je
vous contredit complètement gérard
larcher pas d'accord avec ça il a dit
que c'était aux arènes qui avait le plus
de débats très bien mais je voulais dire
je vous contredit complètement parce que
dans la commission finances en ajoutant
les commissaires insoumis communiste
socialiste et écologiste nous serons
plus nombreux donc en vote nous pourrons
l'emporter face à l'extrême droite donc
le fait d'avoir un groupe unique était
une fausse bonne idée nous l'avons dit
et c'est n était pas l'accord la corse
était augmenter le nombre de députés
écologistes et de gauche le contrat est
rempli c'est x 2 et que chaque
courant parties puissent disposer de son
groupe le contrat est rempli il se
trouve qu'avec plusieurs groupes ça peut
sembler contre intuitif mais on a plus
de parole plus de moyens plus de
capacité de commissions d enquête
parlementaire donc évidemment il faut
plusieurs groupes il n'empêche que dans
la commission des finances nous aurons
plus de commissaires et la question en
fait je la retourne est ce que l om va
faciliter l'accession à la commission
des finances c'était un vrai lieu de
contre-pouvoir d'un des bienfaits du
relationnel value c'est étrange parce
qu'en fait c'est invoqué la tradition
quand on fait elle vous arrange je me
souviens de jean luc mélenchon dans la
campagne dans la campagne des
législatives qui au regard des usages de
l'assemblée nationale réclame et pour la
nuit pour pour son groupe en effet la
commission des finances parce que ça
revenait au premier groupe d'opposition
le problème c'est que c'est passé en
terme de nombre du côté du r n est donc
la plus que c'est une de nos traditions
je vous dis et deuxième usage et odile
et dès que vous vous réclamez de l homme
qui ne votent pas qui est en effet un
usager simplement usages alors qu'encore
une fois vous réclamez que ce ne soit
pas le cas
je réponds factuellement sur les 2 1
c'est pas forcément le premier groupe et
deuxièmement nous sommes le premier
groupe nous aurons le plus de
commissaires sept jeux alors rend pas
votre contradictions deuxième point lrm
lusage c'est qu'effectivement la
majorité ne choisissent pas moi je dis
juste attention à permettre un signe
égal si vous me dites je ne choisis pas
entre des opposants à votre politique et
des adversaires de la république j'y
vois une dérive grave de la macro ni qui
s'était présentée si vous souvenez en
2017 pour faire barrage au front
national et qui en fait sont faits lors
s'en fait le 6 le pied
de guerre groupe c'est valérie rabault
pour nous c'est derrière ben oui c'est
évident que c'est le candidat porté par
la france est soumise la présidence de
la commission des finances elle va à la
nuit baisse et au sein du ps elle est
fille c'est ce qui nous semble le poker
est plus cohérent donc vous acceptez qui
croient et des filles à l'après au
risque que le doux nom marche deux
autres pop pour y séjourner alors ça
pourrait être le cas pour venir vous me
le permettez aux risques qu'on a un
député
bosseur
déterminée et notamment qu'ils puissent
travailler contre l'évasion fiscale on
sait que les grands groupes notamment
mcdonald's eurodisney et autres ne paye
pas les impôts qu'ils devraient payer
dans ce pays et que ça c'est un vrai
grave dysfonctionnement démocratique et
les filles sont quelqu'un de sérieux
eric coquerel il travaille à la
commission des finances ces dernières
années
[Musique]